when you think about the optimism
company when you think about 10 years
out what do you want to build so I I you
know I I hate the term soft skills you
everybody talks about hard skills and
soft skills I hate the term soft skills
there's nothing soft about them and hard
and soft are opposites um uh and these
things are not opposite skills they're
complimentary skills and so um I believe
in human skills um you know hard skills
the skills you need to learn to do your
job you know obviously and I need you to
excel at that human skills the skills
you need to learn to be a better human
being and when you learn the skills of
being a better human being like how to
listen actively how to have empathy how
to have a difficult conversation how to
have an effective confrontation how to
give or receive feedback um turns out um
it's good for business and it's good for
relationships and so I want somebody to
excel at hard skills and human skills
and so we're building the optimism
company company to be the go-to place
for anybody who's looking to improve
their human skills and so if you ask me
what the optimism company look like in
10 years that that I can I can say with
great pride that we are having a
positive impact in the lives of people
who have improved their human skills
because of the stuff that we've been um
offering